as hilda delves deeper into the quest
for her lost father
she will encounter many dangers and
challenges in the city of aphes
let us introduce you to one of the main
adversaries that hilda will have to
confront ulelia
the prey
famous for her beautiful voice ulelia
used to be the most recognized singer
during aphi's glorious golden age
but like so many others
ulia would fall victim to the curse that
spread across the city a thousand years
ago
the famine brought on by the asterigos
changed her into something else
she turned to an evil cult the ethos and
dedicated herself to it becoming a
symbol by using her reputation and voice
to lure more people to join the cult
[Music]
the encounter starts with ulelia flying
around the top of the seats while
sending attacks like voice shock blasts
feather blades
and cyclones
occasionally she'll descend to the
ground to fight hilda herself with even
more dangerous claw and wing strikes
after some back and forth fights ulia
would fly to the sky and use her voice
and feather blades to attack hilda again
and this time she even calls upon
several harpy minions to assist her
during this phase hilda must fight the
minions while watching out for ulelia's
deadly attacks from above
once hilde has dealt with the minions
ulelia will land again and this time
with despair as she will cause feather
storms to swoop around the amphitheater
this is when the battle culminates the
feather storms will continually fire
sharp blades as hell that cautiously
counters ulelia's onslaught in close
combat
in the end only the strongest will
survive
[Music]
we hope you enjoy this preview and we
can't wait to share more about the world
of astarigus with you